that's something that's not often talked
about with the release of gpt4 how much
went into the safety concerns how long
also you spend on the safety concern can
you um can you go through some of that
process yeah sure what went into uh AI
safety considerations of gpt4 release so
we finished last summer
um we immediately started
giving it to people to uh to Red Team
um we started doing a bunch of our own
internal safety efels on it we started
trying to work on different ways to
align it
um
and that combination of an internal and
external effort plus building a whole
bunch of new ways to align the model and
we didn't get it perfect by far but one
thing that I care about is that our
degree of alignment increases faster
than our rate of capability progress
and then I think will become more and
more important over time and
I know I think we made reasonable
progress there to a to a more aligned
system than we've ever had before I
think this is the most capable and most
aligned model that we've put out we were
able to do a lot of testing on it uh and
that takes a while and I totally get why
people were like give us gpt4 right away
but I'm happy we did it this way is
there some wisdom some insights about
that process that you learned like how
to how to solve that problem you can
speak to how to solve it like the
alignment problem so I want to be very
clear I do not think we have yet
discovered a way to align a super
powerful system we have we have
something that works for our current
skill
called rlhf
and we can talk a lot about the benefits
of that and
the utility it provides it's not just an
alignment maybe it's not even mostly an
alignment capability it helps make a
better system a more usable system
and
this is actually something that I don't
think people outside the field
understand enough it's easy to talk
about alignment and capability as
orthogonal vectors they're very close
better alignment techniques lead to
better capabilities and vice versa
there's cases that are different and
they're important cases but on the whole
I think things that you could say like
rlhf or interpretability that sound like
alignment issues also help you make much
more capable models and the division is
just much fuzzier than people think and
so in some sense the work we do to make
gpd4 safer and more aligned looks very
similar to all the other work we do of
solving the research and Engineering
problems associated with creating
useful and Powerful models
so rlhf
is the process that can be applied very
broadly across the entire system where
human basically votes what's the better
way to say something
um what's you know if a person asks do I
look fat in this dress
there's uh there's different ways to
answer that question that's aligned with
human civilization
and there's no one set of human values
or there's no one set of right answers
to human civilization
so I think what's going to have to
happen is we will need to agree on as a
society on very broad bounds we'll only
be able to agree on a very broad bounds
of what these systems can do and then
within those maybe different countries
have different rlh F Tunes certainly
individual users have very different
preferences
we launched this thing with gpt4 called
the system message which is not rlhf but
is a way to let users have a good degree
of
steerability over what they want and I
think things like that will be important
can you describe system message and in
general how you were able to make gpt4
more steerable
foreign
based on the interaction that the user
can have with it which is one of his big
really powerful things so the system
message is a way to say uh you know hey
model please pretend like you or please
only answer this message as if you were
Shakespeare doing thing X or please only
respond uh with Json no matter what was
one of the examples from our blog post
but you could also say any number of
other things to that and then we
we we tune gpt4 in a way to really treat
the system message with a lot of
authority
I'm sure there's jail they'll always not
always hopefully but for a long time
there will be more jailbreaks and we'll
keep sort of learning about those but we
program we develop whatever you want to
call it the model in such a way to learn
that it's supposed to really use that
system message